welcome back to gum unfiltered host by
me josh smith and today we're joined by
wonder woman herself
thank you so much for having me how's it
going
oh babes it's going good and you know
what's going good is one woman
i mean babe you've come out you've
slayed it once again
oh you just gave me you gave me the
truth thank you
this world is not yet ready for all that
you will do
your time will come diana
and everything will be different
it's all kind of about the personal
struggles we go through and how we use
those struggles to
ultimately empower us right right how
have you used some struggles in your
life
to empower you would you say oh
i think it's the being able to
prevail some difficult or complex or
[Music]
stressful situations and really going
through them and prevailing them
is when i feel like i'm empowered um
facing them what kind of stressful
situations do you feel like you have to
face oh babe just you know just the
normal stuff that's
that's you know working moms has to
the balance between having a career and
and and you know having um
family uh it's something that is always
handful and and and both my career takes
a lot and of course my family takes a
lot and i have two
very young children so the the finding
the balance and always trying to do my
best is
is is my biggest thing
i mean the juggle is real isn't it the
juggle is real dude
get used to it
i remember being one for rules the
answer is always
more
the way i fly they will never find us i
forgot to tell you
what radar will they will they shoot at
us
this is also a lot about physical and
mental strength this character like she
really has to dive deep into her own
mental strength
and also her fizzle strength for
different times what do you think this
role
in particular has taught you about your
own mental and
physical strength would you say i've
never shot a movie
that that was so hard this movie was
just like the hardest movie i've ever
got to
work on it's both physically and
emotionally but also
the longevity of everything we shoot the
movie for eight months and we prep for
it for four
six months ahead of the shoot like it's
just
a lot and the fact and i'm a
perfectionist too with
everything that i do so wherever i am i
try to give my everything
so just to me what empowers me is
the the knowing that
i gave my best every day everywhere to
everyone
and i did it you know and and you take
it day
by day by day by day until you do it
and you just learn how to perfect it and
how to make it
work better for you and how to handle
everything in a
in a way that it's working best for you
but to me this is my
biggest struggle how do you manage your
own
self-critic in that sense do you still
have a salary um
yes of course i have uh of course i have
how do i handle it i don't
i just it is what it is
and what can you do well babe keep on
saying it
we love to see it thank you so much
i'm speaking to you and big love to you
and keep making it
wonder woman babe thank you so much bye